uh
hey everybody what's up we are back
we're still alive you can you can hear
us right
yeah please tell me you can get inside
check sound check
sound check sound cause i don't ever
know if it's working anymore yeah so
uh we're back you're getting an extra
bonus show because we had to cut it
short yesterday i mean
it's like the show was like five hours
but it's like we didn't finish yeah
because dude i wanted to finish the list
and i wanted to talk about that elisa
lam documentary and that stupid nostril
we can do we have enough time right now
sounds good looks good
because i was looking at how much you
had left material and i was going man
that's about enough i only had two more
lists it wasn't
but it wasn't hammered like we were it
would have been about
been a long time because i was measuring
what the rate we were moving at
before but then like some people are
like damn you
tom's rushing the show he's shutting it
down well i was dealing with another
problem at the same time
our computer was [ __ ] up and it kept
i knew it was going to fall at any
moment
yeah we were like paranoid that it was
going to drop the stream today
and and when it falls jenny [ __ ]
loses it
she starts [ __ ] smacking [ __ ] in here
and everything i'm like calm down calm
down
the microphone's still going i'm like
chill out you know we'll get them right
back on
and you see people understand though
they get mad at technology
it's not just me jenny is
she's fun to get drunk with all right
we kind of manifest drunkness in
different ways
i [ __ ] kind of start from here and i
get more fun more fun more for it i
start peeking
and then all of a sudden i disappear i
stopped talking
yeah he just got all right the
bartenders know when i've had enough
because i stopped talking all right
and then they look over watching jenny
and jenny starts picking on me because
jenny
goes up she goes up she
becomes fun she's fun for a little for
for a long time and then but sometimes
if anything negative happens
like i stopped talking or this and that
she kind of turns on me you're a [ __ ]
i'm doing like this sometimes it doesn't
happen all the time
[Laughter]
but last night i was having a blast it's
like i could drink and talk about horror
movies all night and i was like no i
wasn't worried i don't want to stop
i was worried because she was right at
that damn point where she it's like
where it's gonna go one way or the other
all right and i was afraid that if it
crashed again
that she'd go [ __ ] off and get
frustrated and then she'd go into a
[ __ ] spiral
and by the time the show came back she'd
be she'd be [ __ ] pissed off
she'd on the show that wouldn't have
been that's what i thought i mean it
would piss me off like in the moment i'd
be like god damn it again
then she's like looking at me going on
the show you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
no because i just wanted to keep talking
about horror movies like i said i'll
drink and talk about horror movies
sometimes when i'm at the club and you
know what i'm drinking and like one of
our friends is there and we start
talking about horror movies i'll stand
there at the bar for like four hours and
like talk to [ __ ] people about horror
movies i love it
as well you know i i was pretty hammered
so i was maybe it was a little bit
paranoid
but i was trying to get the show moving
i was looking at how much i had left and
i was going like man there's at least
two
three hours worth of material left at
the rate we're going i can't last two or
three and i don't think she's gonna last
because she was
you were [ __ ] going pear-shaped i was
going pear-shaped well yeah it was all
the show was going sideways it was
it was better to [ __ ] bow out before
the [ __ ] became a total [ __ ] disaster
but it's all recorded for [ __ ]
posterity you guys can [ __ ] watch it
you might be able to see the [ __ ]
gears moving in my mind i was like
jenny's [ __ ] loaded this [ __ ]
computer crashes she's gonna [ __ ]
blow
and then
and then by the time we get back on
she's gonna be calling me all kinds of
[ __ ]
no i wasn't i wasn't i wasn't going down
that way telling me that i'm talking too
much on the damn show
i wouldn't have got mad at you i was i
would've been mad at the computer but i
get mad at the computer
well i get mad at all my computers i get
mad at like
inanimate objects when they don't do
what i want them to do which is like all
the time so i woke up this morning and i
was like
man we kind of [ __ ] over the audience
we didn't finish that list and [ __ ]
was just starting to get good
so i said jenny we ought to just go
ahead and give another stream and she's
like yeah we can do that
yeah and we're just not gonna drink
tonight we got lemonade that's it yeah
this is seriously this is just lemonade
there's not
there's no vodka in it it's just
lemonade i can only drink maybe [ __ ]
twice
twice a week you know what i mean yeah
because i mean when we do drink
like on the saturday one and stuff it's
yeah it is kind of a lot
yeah it takes me a while to recover i'm
[ __ ] 50. it's weird though because
like i said the whole thing with the
aspirin and everything
um that really has saved me having
hangovers the only thing that i'll have
the next i don't have a hangover the
next day if i remember to take the
aspirin which i did last night
but um i'll just be a little bit sleepy
like the following afternoon
you know yeah but um but i won't feel
bad i don't get headaches or
feel sick or anything like that yeah i
just feel sleepy
but not till afternoon bee's nest says
tom is supposed to inject testosterone
dressed
directly into your testicles no you're
not doink
yeah i got stories about that [ __ ] you
can tell tom's too drunk when he just
sits there with his arms crossed
yeah yeah i start shutting down
um yeah that's another thing is that
they they that was another contributing
factor to last night
they warned me they said [ __ ] the
first few days maybe two or three days
on this [ __ ]
[ __ ] hrt that [ __ ] you're going to
be kind of erratic and i i'm
i'm [ __ ] up a little bit i'm kind of
like if i'm not
yeah he's been all over the place been
all over the place if i'm not doing
something or keep myself occupied i'll
go through [ __ ] all the major
emotions in about [ __ ] an
hour you know what i mean and you get
kind of glitchy
it's kind of like the closest thing i
can describe it is like uh
really nicking for a cigarette and
getting a little tiny drag you're going
i want more that one more that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you feel like you're grinding your teeth
yeah and you go
oh god god damn damn yeah he does this
[Laughter]
it'll even out over time but they say
that first couple days you might be
kinda
glitchy that's a good word for it yeah
when did you get the injection not
yesterday was it yesterday yesterday
yesterday was day one
i think it was yesterday yeah it was it
was yesterday was day one no it was
tuesday
tuesday yeah that's right because we
went to the we went to the
um post office first on monday but it
was president's day so it was closed
um so we went back on tuesday so it was
tuesday yeah so about three i'm on day
three there
yeah yeah that wasn't really a day
though that was just that
thing exactly that was the end of a day
that when i got the injection
yeah so it wasn't in the beginning of
the day it'll work out though zach said
i've been drunk to the point of puking
and passing out and still not have a
hangover
never had any in fact is that weird
you're very lucky it might just because
you're younger though
yeah um you're young you don't have them
very much yeah
also depends on what you drink yeah what
you drink if you eat afterward
like i said i haven't had too much
trouble
you know since i take because i'll drink
a bunch of water and then take three
aspirin and then i usually feel
you know pretty much fine the next day
no headaches no nothing like that
sometimes i'll be real thirsty and like
i said
you know when it gets to be around like
three or four the in the next afternoon
i'll get real real sleepy
um because i'm kind of sleepy right now
but but i don't feel
bad though yeah sandra says oh man
apparently uh
tom apparently makes very strong drinks
i can't remember jenny being
drunk that fast before yeah what
happened was
is if i start feeling good i lose my
poor discipline yeah he's just like i'm
like i'll just pour it
yeah i should drink that i'm not really
thinking
and i don't know how much is in there
because he's out in the kitchen and i've
been here talking show them that glass
show them that glass and like i said
this is just that much vodka in it
i put the ice and then the yeah so it
was half and half
okay see i didn't with ice in it yeah i
can't really
you can't tell yeah that vodka is real
smooth
and that's what i mean it doesn't have
lemonade that's real i made that
lemonade
and it's just real lemony it disappears
right into it yeah
and i forgot you know because i'm
[ __ ] i'm lit i'm like you're like
we're having a good time it's the party
stream for me yeah
yeah there's more for me
[Laughter]
that kind of [ __ ] so like i said i have
no idea how much booze is in the drinks
that's how i just make them
that's how i plate up food too i'll put
more food on there than i could eat it
just looked good at the time
i'd be like oh well because yeah and i i
had to keep him from like doing that
because i was like dude i'm gonna weigh
400 pounds is that what you want
i was like because sometimes they'll
bring the bowl and it's like this big
i'm like dude i can't eat all that
yeah and i can't eat it either it's just
it just seems like a good idea
i made it so i'm gonna put it on the
plate and then i realized [ __ ] man this
is like [ __ ] four portions
yeah yeah his eyes are bigger than his
stomach
yeah although you've kind of uh the
the stuff you're on is um taking your
appetite away you said yeah i'm not
hungry
we just made he made um like uh three
pork in the pool slow cooker yeah
[ __ ] uh
and made some little tacos like carnatus
yeah yeah
so coco carnitas they have [ __ ]
cocoa powder in it yeah that's [ __ ]
good the mexicans showed me that
it's got cumin [ __ ] red chili pepper
a little bit of cayenne
cocoa powder salt and a little bit of um
what do you call it i forgot clove i
should have put a little bit of clove in
there so
slow cooked it in there pulled all the
fat and the bones out of it and then you
refry it to get the brown edges on it
i was making tacos [ __ ] with mustard
cheese on corn
with [ __ ] coleslaw mix on top
salsa i made three of them for her and
three of them for me and i've ate two of
them and
he couldn't start getting that third one
i said i'm not really hungry
yeah and i mean and i got about i was
forcing myself to eat that last half and
normally i could eat five of them things
yeah i'm just like man i don't think i
like this
and and you said it was great yeah and
it tasted good to me it just i had no
appetite i threw it away
well that might be something to do with
like hormones yeah yeah that it's like
causing all kind of creams i'm pregnant
you heard it here first oh he's pregnant
pregnant
some [ __ ] no they were delicious tacos
yeah i ate the three of them that's all
i've eaten oh the carnitas was [ __ ]
great how could they have been bad when
i first tasted those carnitas i'm like
oh man that's [ __ ] good
yeah i'm gonna eat all of that but then
you couldn't eat it no
oh another thing i forgot to tell them
was that once i had them carnitas down
in there to refry them
i poured all the the leftover juices
from the jalapenos
you know the jalapeno i put all that in
there oh [ __ ] and cooked all that down
to get that jalapeno [ __ ]
uh uh seasoning into that meat it was
good yeah that's what
part of that [ __ ] flavor and also
when i slow cooked it i forgot to
mention
that i had it in orange juice yeah yeah
about a cup of orange juice in there it
just that meat just [ __ ]
fell off the bone yeah to 260 degrees
covered inside a damn pot
all night i woke up in the morning and i
was like what that smell oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dj maniac said my mom keeps sending over
food even when i have a fridge full that
has expiration dates approaching and
it's driving me mad
yeah yeah i know it's just kind of like
you know there's there's only i you know
i can only eat so much like i said i'm
trying to lose weight so it's just kind
of like
i i don't really like to buy too much
uh perishable food because i'm like i
don't know how long it's going to take
me to eat this stuff
bee's nest goes to [ __ ] uh mexico
about every day and he he loves carnitas
on torta bread
with grilled onions and avocado that
sounds really good sounds amazing
that tortoise torted bread i always have
uh
some of that indian naan in there i
wonder if that would work because that
also i saw
taco bell using that indian naan on
gorgita's
yeah i saw that [ __ ] and i went there i
was like man that's not mexican that's
[ __ ] indian
that's indian bread yeah it was good
though well like i said it's close
yeah i mean it's not rigged it's you
know
naan is like similar to like [ __ ]
pita bread yeah
it's all kind of not yeah well it's it's
kind it's flat
yeah there's a difference but but not
you can use them either one and [ __ ]
we've made pizza
using naan if we didn't feel like making
dough yeah it's real good
just put it in there on the stone like
whatever all right
okay you about ready to get on this list
okay now we did the 90s yeah
let me see we did the 90s right chronos
yeah we did candy man
yeah we did all that sales and lamps
yeah we defragged this computer so
hopefully it won't crash
but like i said if it does we'll see
we'll see if it does i'm going to smack
it i'm telling you right now
because it's it has to learn its lesson
[Laughter]
if she loses it you guys will understand
i'm not well
you know like i said i'm not gonna like
[ __ ] you know kill anybody
well you're not drunk so you're not
drunk so you're not gonna lose it that
bad anyway
i mean i still get frustrated like i
said not just with this computer with
all my computers whenever they do
anything or they're
being too slow i'm just kind of like
yeah maybe yeah
nana's fluffier than peter peter has a
pocket in the middle of it yeah
there's a big difference non non is it
it's
it's flour but it's yogurt and water and
i don't even think there's any uh
yeast in it at all if i remember
correctly
you can make it real quick yogurt water
and some flour
naan is leavened excuse me uh peta's
slightly leavened i believe
oh now i'm kind of curious to look up
it's greek or middle eastern
yeah you know and not no not in india
pure
but i like i said i saw years back
in the 90s i got one of those gorgitas
and looked at that and it was like
a piece of naan with a flour tortilla
and a [ __ ] corn tortilla all with
it's like one inside the other inside
the other and i said man that's indian
that's not
mexican but i don't know how they do it
in in mexico but you know if you're
looking to
taco bell for authenticity yeah of
anything
um even authenticity of food in general
yeah um it's probably
not you're gonna have a bad time they're
making a million
they're making they're making a million
sellable items out of [ __ ] five
components
thank you thank you thank you greetings
from london love all your postings
learning so much thanks mr hennessy he's
probably learning
how drunk we can get not tonight though
because we're learning this
[Laughter]
yeah like in the pub yeah like back of
the pub
saunders says i notice it much more when
jenny gets drunk tom is always the same
no matter what
which is really funny because ironically
at the club it's opposite like the
bartenders are like man jenny's really
good at hiding drunk and tommy is it
okay now if if jenny's surrounded by a
bunch of her girlfriends
you can't tell she's drunk because she's
just they're all running their mouths
they're all excited me i'll be yeah
because we're all like talking about
yeah i'll be on the other side just
slowly i start kind of slouching and
getting slower
and um you okay
yeah yeah i'm good and then she'll turn
around and go you [ __ ] loser
and you're like that you know i called
you a [ __ ] thing
i just like i like to kick people when
they're down you know
that's just what my personality is like
it's not it's not
serious i don't mean it like seriously
it's just funny to me that like
because you're kind of like that too
you're kind of like oh it goes back and
forth well yeah it's like you know you
kind of make like mean jokes about
people and stuff like that so i'm just
like oh you can't retaliate so i'm gonna
i'm gonna get all over your [ __ ]
cases yeah because you can't like yell
at me
[ __ ] well you know we're kind of used to
it it's like
it's a weird dynamic i guess that [ __ ]
yeah i know right so so okay so we did
the 90s yeah
yeah um i remembered you in the 90s so i
wasn't that drunk
because i remember you saying but we got
a lot of the 2000 no 2000
oh it's 2010 to 21. yeah okay
see that's what i told you i only had
two more lists okay i thought
that's why i'm sitting there going dude
but there's like three more lists
the 2000s and then i was like well it's
only 20 21 it's like a decade
we can't uh scroll though when we
scrolled last time the [ __ ] computer
was crashing so yeah but i
but i always scrolled before and it
didn't do anything well we can finish
this and then we can do all the other
stuff that you prepared we'll talk about
the damn hey adam sane from conspira
normal in the house how you doing
[ __ ] how you doing adam what's up
manny
yeah how's the show been i hadn't
checked your show in a while
yeah been [ __ ] busy up here
yeah yeah adam's had a science adams had
you on many of the shows i think i was
on one of them you've been on a bunch
and then
well i did a bunch of after-hours stuff
yeah you've done some like uh patreon
online patreon only stuff yeah which
that's just the funnest really the
patreon because [ __ ] he's wanting me
to cut loose
i'll start cutting loose tom loose yeah
[Laughter]
okay so that says at least you admit it
jenny admit what that i'm a dick
i freely admit that okay i kind of admit
it
[Laughter]
i'm not always
we got a pretty good crowd in here now
yeah yeah um
all right so now we're we're at the
2000s and like i said i cut because i
kind of wanted to talk about the
nostradamus [ __ ] and the elisa lampshade
yeah we'll talk about that
so we'll do this first though because i
i felt bad that we didn't get to the
last yeah
once people were just starting to get
interest you know get excited about the
show and we had to cut it short
yeah for alcoholic reasons for alcoholic
reasons yeah let me put the slide off
the show
[ __ ] was going parachutes at least we
mostly cut we got like the 70s and 80s
covered which i feel like is probably
what most people are interested in
um but all right so this is going to be
the 2000s
yeah uh so at number 20 got a little
movie from 2003 called
dead end i've never seen this one now if
you have not seen this movie
it's i think it's on 2b for free uh or
it was
um a couple months ago ray wise is in it
from you know he was in twin peaks and
everything lynn shea is in it
and it's basically about this family and
they're driving somewhere for christmas
and it's this really cool like surreal
like all this weird surreal [ __ ] like
happens
on this road you know what i mean i
don't want to spoil anything but it's
really really good and i feel like
i don't know i just i really dug it and
i feel like a lot of people don't really
talk about it
so uh oh sandra's seen it yes dead end
is great i've never seen it
oh it's good it's really really good i
really like it okay
i kept the reason i ended up seeing it
and i saw it not too long ago is because
it kept coming up
on you know why doesn't anybody talk
about this movie or like best underrated
horror movies
and i was like man that's right there on
tv i should watch that
and it's really really good um number 19
may oh 2002. i liked this movie
directed by lucky mckee yeah shutter
just added his other movie the woman but
i haven't watched it yet
um and this uh had angela bettis in it
they have they work together a lot
but yeah this is like about a lonely
girl who decides she's going to make a
friend
in a frankensteinie sort of fashion yeah
it's a good movie it's a real it's a
real good low budget
kind of goth horror movie yeah it's kind
of neat yeah
kind of like something kind of reminds
me of like edward gory drawings
that's what that's what that's what the
uh yeah that's what it kind of reminds
me of that
yeah i always really liked it because
even though she's a murderer
you still kind of feel bad for her i
mean you know what i mean
because she's just like wow yeah she's
kind of pitiful because she's like well
she never meets anybody
like she everybody she meets they have
like one or two cool things about them
but then they have like a bunch of
shitty things about them so she decides
well i'm just going to take the best
parts of the people and put them all
together into one perfect person
yeah it's pretty good movie yeah it's
like and it has like a really kind of
weirdly heartwarming ending all right
number 18 is drag me to hell drag me to
hell 2 000 2009 florence i feel like
people were talking about this
comments it's sam raimi
and uh it's a horror con i remember
seeing this one in the theater and it's
so it's so
fun you would probably love it okay it's
basically it's about this
woman this young woman and she is a loan
officer
and so they have you know your quote
unquote like
gypsy woman who comes in there is trying
to get a loan and this girl
turns her down so she gets cursed so
it's like a gypsy curse
movie and it's really it's like i said
it's super super fun
it's super gross like this poor girl
that's in this movie like gets so many
fluids and
snakes and bugs and worms and just like
all kind of [ __ ] like poured all over
oh it's so so fun i just really really
liked it you'd probably love it
okay i feel like um so that's probably
one that uh that you need to see because
you like all the evil dead moves it has
that kind of vibe to it and it's
it's real funny and it's like real gory
um let's see number 17
wreck 2007. now this is the original
spanish one and like i said i'm not a
huge fan of found footage but this was
probably one of the best found footage
movies ever
uh they remade it they did like an
american version that i think was called
quarantine
which was not great but it's basically
about an
outbreak in an apartment building and
like i said it's like people that live
in the apartment they're kind of
you know they're doing it found footage
style and it's just really really well
done it's like really really
easy
yeah um so yeah like i said even if you
don't like found footage movies it's
really really good for
like easily one of the best found
footage movies all right this next one
is one of my favorites
number 16. dagon from
it's so funny i feel like a lot of
people don't like this movie they don't
know what they're talking about but
to me this one really conveyed
the whole like damp fishy
uh aesthetic of lovecraftian movie yeah
it just i was there was something about
it that really kind of like and i love
love love
um the the queen girl
like without with her little weird crown
and all the tentacles and everything
it's this pretty spanish girl in a damn
i still want to do that for a halloween
costume she's in a wheelchair you don't
know what the deal is and all these
monsters you know
she's related to all these monsters
turns out she's a monster too it's a
really good movie
dagon i have it on blu-ray i got it i
got it actually
i have the special release they had a
very limited yeah blu-ray release of it
and um it's the same company that did uh
from beyond and um yeah and uh
all the other uh lovecraft movies that
had oh what's his name in it
jeffrey combs he's not in this one he's
not in it they got another guy who's
kind of like him but but you know he's a
jeffrey combs stand-in
he's kind of like a jeffrey come stand
in i would say
but this is made at a time when
jefferies combs had aged out of the role
that he was supposed to be
supposed to be a college student yeah so
you know there's no way jeffrey calms
gonna
pull himself off as a college student
but
it's probably the best out of those
movies made by that company
just visually really good special
effects great music
uh good story um
real real faithful to lovecraftian
lore i liked it although it's not really
based on the story dagon
it's based on um
yeah yeah yeah yeah um yeah what the
[ __ ] is that that's what it's like yeah
so it's happening on an island yeah it's
more sense it's on an island off the
coast of spain or greece i don't
remember
which one i'm pretty sure it was spain
because i think that's where they shot
this
yeah it was just kind of like some of
the later uh reanimator movie like
not beyond reanimate or whatever the one
like the the newer one that they
shot that in spain too he had a real
famous spanish actor in it
you know who is kind of like their
version of brando he's in it
he plays old balm he's the last human
being that's been living in the damn
island and they're
man he he speaks in english but you
can't really understand
it but he does this great little
monologue where he
tells how the cult of dagon took over
and they flash
back to the to the times when he was a
kid when it took over
it's actually i thought it was the best
he was
gold and fish from the sea
remember they said you sounded like box
yeah
fish from the sea yeah plus that guy
came to a real bad end in this movie
yeah yikes stay gone
[Laughter]
all right number 15. here's another one
i don't think you've seen this one tom
uh behind the mask the rise of leslie
vernon
this one i adore this movie
it's just so well done it's basically
it's a mockumentary
about a team that are making they're
making a documentary about
a serial killer who is trying to be but
in the universe of this movie
um like jason and uh you know
leatherface and several
are real people are real serial killers
and this guy is trying to be like a
legend like they are
so this documentary team is like
following him around
and he's like telling them like all
these [ __ ] pointers
you know what i mean like for serial
killer for being like a famous movie
serial killer
and it is hilarious it's hilarious it's
just really really well done like the
way they play with all the slasher
tropes
um it's just funny as hell and it's
really really it's
gory it's just really really fun
sorry pat go back and see dagon again
man it's it's the same tone as the other
movies that that
yeah it's sort of maybe was had some
funny [ __ ]
they had some funny but they all did
yeah i don't really remember yeah that
much funny stuff yeah
you know they would they would have
little comedic spots in it here and
there but
but that company you know from beyond
did also and so did reanimator was
[ __ ] hilarious
you know go back and watch reanimator
embroidery animator and [ __ ]
all the reanimator series uh you know
it's one of my favorite series and it
did
there's a lot of comedy in them yeah i
kind of feel like daegon was the least
comedic
yeah of that yeah because i mean
re-animator i would straight
that that is a straight-up horror comedy
yeah i mean it's up there with like uh
evil dead
yeah yeah yeah it's the same kind of
goofy over the top which i love
that [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] yeah see that's
what i mean it's like you you like a lot
of horror with um
you know comedic yeah stuff in it um
let's see what else have we got here
number 14 american psycho
from 2000 yeah this yeah
this just [ __ ] good movie i
i just i just love this movie so much
christian bale is was like the perfect
person to play that [ __ ]
role cause he just he comes across as
just so
soulless yeah you know what i mean like
he's really really good at playing that
character
it's a classic movie like creepily good
yeah it's
quite it's become a classic over the
years it's good shadow over in his mouth
thank you dj maniac that's right i was
like
i was like yeah shadow over ren's mouth
that was the end of the story
yeah it's it so it's not they called it
dagon but it's
actually shadow of a friend's mouth but
i guess dagon's like a better title and
they do talk about the cult of dagon
just like they know the story so you
know what i mean it's hard to adapt
anything lovecraft to a movie
because it's just the the original
writings are so much kind of like in
narrative
kind of kind of like and and written
something
like found footage type stuff yeah it's
uh
like he like called the cthulhu was like
that was mostly
wasn't it i remember mostly like third
person and
well you know what dude right telling
about what had happened yeah
yeah i kind of feel like we found
footage we might have
brought this up before but it's like i
you know obviously for my witching hour
show and stuff i read a lot of victorian
era and like early 20th century horror
and that was a very very very very
common trope
um and i don't know if they were doing
it so it would seem more realistic
because they'd always have it was always
either
somebody like talking to you the reader
and saying i'm gonna tell you about like
some scary [ __ ] that happened to me
or it's somebody going i found this
manuscript of some scary [ __ ] that
happened to this other person yeah and
then they present it
then then you read these letters that
came from this guy
and yet dracula was like that
yeah and lovecraft i think was copying
those kind of writers
because he i would read lovecraft when i
was a kid you know in high school and
everybody was talking about it you know
before there was an iron maiden albums
and everything
and they were it was good to it
it was a good read when you're a kid i
really couldn't put up with it now it's
super verbose you had to damn grab a
[ __ ]
dictionary to figure out what he was
talking about a lot of times just trying
to show his vocabulary off but that was
just the style of the time
everything's real so flowery you flowery
and making up words and stuff
and it was kind of mysterious it did
have a mysterious tone to it
hey i've i found the only thing about
lovecraft is he used a lot of the same
words like he had some of the words that
he really really used to eldritch over
and over again yeah a lot
here yeah i mean it's a cool word yeah
i'm not saying i'm just saying that
that turned up in like a bunch of it
yeah preach i think he was preacher
natural wasn't that pretty
or was that or was that that was uh anne
rice that used that a lot preaching oh
does she have i haven't read any anne
rice in a long time so it's like i can't
so i can't remember then like yeah it
was
i think what lovecraft was going for was
a found footage effect yeah
because you know it was you know you're
not talking about film it's books so but
it's kind of like a found
footage book yes that's what i'm saying
i think that that's
it it gave it like a sense of veracity
so
i think that authors at the time thought
well this will make it scarier because
it will seem like something that really
happened
it was real high tech back in the day
yeah cause like you said dracula was
like that that was all
you know uh diary entries and letters
and
newspaper articles and stuff it was
written entirely
they're trying to take you there yeah
which like i said that's
that's a cool and it's exactly it's like
the same principle as found footage
you're just trying to get like you know
that very similar to
they think it like makes it scarier yeah
all right so yeah american psycho that
was number 14.
number 13 gonna go with trick or treat
yeah 2007. yeah good movie one of my
favorite
um anthology horror anthologies if you
liked creepshow and stuff you'd go like
this
and it was so amazing i mean the
halloween just bleeds out of this one
it is just so halloweeny what i liked
about this is that it was just
it was uh all practical effects
and it was really good color palette
good shots you know i mean shot
composition was really good
it it had a real good flow that i liked
the edit to it
and uh things that happened in one house
and go across the street and something
else would happen it was [ __ ] cool i
liked it
yeah i really liked the way they edited
it together and the fact that they could
take
like the little character of sam and
make that such an iconic halloween
character like in this day and age i
think was like really got to see that
one again
yeah we have that don't we yeah i'm
pretty sure we have it on blu-ray
i try to watch it every halloween just
because it puts me in the mood
you know what i mean it's because it's
just so so halloweeny and i love
anything that can like nail the [ __ ]
halloween tone like that i'm just i'm
super into it
um all right so let's see where we
number 12
let the right one in from 2008
now they did um they did an
english language remake of this because
it's what swedish
i want to say um and
it wasn't bad actually chloe grace
moritz was in it
um but obviously the original is way
better
um i don't know if you've seen it or not
i read the book as well like a long time
ago the book is also very good
but it's basically it's a vampire story
but
it's the vampire is a little girl but
she's like
hundreds of years old sounds familiar
and she makes friends with this bullied
little boy yeah yeah yeah
um yeah it's a really really good and
it's really you know really gory i just
so i really like that one and like i
said i'm not gonna [ __ ] on the american
remake i'm not a big fan of them being
like oh well this foreign language movie
you know everybody loved that so let's
make an american version because people
don't
won't read subtitles or whatever um but
i'm not gonna [ __ ] on the remake too bad
because the the remake was actually
pretty decent i think the whole uh
making an american remake is
uh it's a good marketing strategy though
when you think about it it is well
obviously or they wouldn't do it yeah
you already have the a movie made the
idea and everything let's just make it
again in english
these people over here haven't seen it
yet so it makes sense
you know the english speaking market is
huge because it's america
canada australia uk yeah
so it's covering it's covering a big
territory you're cashing in again
yeah basically yeah yeah i mean i don't
know because i feel like in the 90s
there was a massive
you know because j horror like asian
horror was really
that was kind of the thing and so it
seemed like every
asian horror movie that did any bit of
business and that people were talking
about over here they're like
we got to do an american remake and some
of them
most of them were okay but i mean i'll
get to
the only one that i think was like worth
the [ __ ] no no okay that's that's a lie
because actually
the um i liked the american remake of
dark water i don't know if it was as
good as the original the japanese one
but it was it wasn't bad it was actually
pretty good and i've seen it a couple
times
you know what i mean so it's weird
because when we're talking about dark
water
uh that kind of ties into the elisa lam
case too which i think we mentioned on
the
dermot said he watched trick or treat on
uh last week on our uh
advice and he absolutely loved it it's
so good
it's just so it just infuses me with
halloween spirit
spirit you know what i mean it's i love
it i just love the look of it i just
love it it's all orange and [ __ ] i love
it
um all right number 11 dog soldier yes
2002. it's a real good real good
werewolf yeah british army fights
werewolves yeah and the werewolves in it
look
gray yeah about like a wolf and a net
wolf and um
howling yeah werewolf that and
like and they and i love that they like
i think it's a pretty
pretty much all practical effects like
those werewolf suits it was just like
people on [ __ ] stilts or whatever
wasn't it
yeah i liked it had it was kind of i
think they were british special forces
guys maybe sas or something
yeah something like that yeah they were
out training yeah based on the weapons
that they had it was pretty cool
yeah i liked it and what i really liked
about is that uh it was just kind of
all on the back of some good costumes
good writing
you know with good storytelling and some
decent actors some good actors you don't
and it that didn't cost a lot of money
to make
no it didn't actually but that's you
know it doesn't have to cost a lot of
money to be a good movie
well like like we said before it's like
writing a script doesn't cost anything
yeah they don't pay the damn riders
hardly
even though we're the ones that come up
with the [ __ ] ideas god damn it right
you can tell them a little bitter about
that kind of [ __ ] um yeah so dog
soldiers we did a review of that a while
back
number 10 shadow of the vampire
this is from 2000 i saw this in the
theater when it came out
it's basically john malkovich is in it
um willem dafoe is in it
it's about the making of nosferatu
you were telling me about that yeah um
and uh it's
it posits that max shrek the actor that
played nosferatu in the movie
was an actual vampire that that's how
much
fw murnau the director wanted
um you know wanted all this like realism
in the film as he actually went and
found an actual vampire
to be in nosferatu so it's kind of like
and i mean honestly i love because i
love like the whole aesthetic of like
silent films and i love like all the
[ __ ] from the 20s and all that's i love
the look of that
i got to see this one yeah so it's you
know i don't know
i guess it's a horror movie because he
start like the vampire starts like
[ __ ] killing people and stuff
but it's kind of almost
it has drama elements and a lot of it is
like a black comedy
yeah but it's just it was seemed like
when that movie came out and like i said
it came out in 2000 i went and saw it in
theater i'm like
this somebody made this movie for me
these are this is like my exact taste in
[ __ ]
and somebody took all of the [ __ ] that i
like and made a movie about it
and it's super super fun gotta give a
shout out though to [ __ ] klaus kinski
and his version of nosferatu
i know his version enough for our two
was pretty good so weird
weird that was a weird ass movie we did
we did a review on that
that's kind of like uh that's kind of
like how i would
imagine a vampire from from the original
story though
yeah you know he was sick yeah and ugly
yeah and just [ __ ] you know like this
nasty [ __ ]
wherever he went diseases and [ __ ]
pestilence went well yeah he was almost
kind of like a humanization of a plague
is what he was so he
kind of looked rat like in his voice and
everything what did you say it was just
like a creepy [ __ ]
wasn't it wasn't sexy at all it was just
like no
you're like ew yeah well yeah he's
like climbed out of a grave he probably
smelled really bad yeah well you know
the vampires don't wear deodorant the
oopier or the
jumper or whatever you want to call it
back in the damn honky motherland was
something that just came out of the damn
grave had blown on its mouth and
yeah it was all gross like more zombie
like yeah like
because i feel like i'm not averse to
like sexy vampires but i do kind of feel
like the original vampire lore when they
were
yeah they were like ghouls essentially
they were like walking around dead
bodies and that other vampire from that
new one what was called blood vessel
that was a cool vampire too i liked
those yeah and his wife
yeah little rat big old rat people kind
of like rat bats yeah maybe i mean along
with that in like 30 days of night and
stuff maybe we're seeing
kind of you know more a slow return to
vampires actually being monsters
they're talking man i understood what he
said
but what the [ __ ] language was that you
know what i mean it was romanian [ __ ]
yeah
which is of course it's just like
portuguese pretty much
it's not it's it's the same grammar and
you can understand it
but i didn't know what language it was
yeah but romanian and portuguese are
real close
isn't that weird yeah well it's not that
weird romania was the land of the romans
yeah it's a romance language yeah you
know it's similar to portuguese
yeah but yeah you should probably see
shadow of the vampire you'd probably dig
it i think that
might be on 2b as well because i just
recently like maybe two months ago i
just rewatched it yeah
um and i think i think i watched it on
tv
i can't remember it it's on one of the
services that we have
um number nine 28 days later
2002 uh danny boyle
zombie movie i guess it's sort of a
zombie movie i know there's like there
was like a big argument that came out
they're not zombies they have the rage
viruses because they're not dead people
that are walking around they're people
that have an
illness that makes them i thought it was
pretty good yeah it's really it's
you know i honestly that shot where he
wakes up
in the hospital all by himself and then
goes out in the middle of
london is just like empty yeah that
for 2002 like a movie this low budget
that mo that shot still like [ __ ]
blows me away
how they [ __ ] did that it's like
how'd you get everybody
to leave that's like it's like it's
crazy it's just like a crazy
talking shot as soon as you said that
made me think of man we got to remake
[ __ ] omega man
i just wish somebody would do
a good adaptation or a faithful
adaptation
of i am legend yeah why is that so hard
i am legend is cool but for some reason
i want to remake
a mega man yeah which is a remake of
kind of like a spin-off or remake of it
there's something about
the [ __ ] that happened in omega man the
people with the cloaks and the
neville and all that you know that could
be redone
yeah and it'd be really cool well it's
probably about time i mean
how long has it been since the will
smith i am legend came out that was
terrible
i did not like that at all well and like
i said they just really
it wasn't too bad until it started
getting to the end and they just like
negated the whole [ __ ] point of the
story which really like
the big mistake is that it wasn't a one
a worldwide pandemic
it was just in one little area oh that's
right they did do that
yeah so where's the sense of the loss of
hope
yeah i mean the whole point of the story
was that he was like the last
man on person right yeah yeah right i
mean honestly the vincent price one
is the closest to the book yeah really
and even that like takes some liberties
but that's the closest one
yeah the whole idea is that you're the
last man and there's all these damn
vampiric mutants and they see you as a
monster because you're going around
killing them in their sleep a relic of
the past
yeah that you're a relic of that that's
exactly what your point of it is it's
like because from their point of
point of view you are you're a monster
around killing them while they're asleep
and [ __ ] with guns yeah yeah so you know
and like i said i just i just feel like
i mean the vincent price one was pretty
close but
it kind of got that vibe but i don't
know they haven't really done it
done it justice i don't think uh number
eight
session nine from 2001. we did a review
on this
not too long ago this is another
another thing where you just get a bunch
of really good actors
a [ __ ] kick-ass location that
abandoned mental hospital you can shoot
the whole [ __ ] thing in there for
practically nothing or relatively
nothing
and it's a great [ __ ] movie it's
super creepy
it's just like it's great and like so
much of it is just like implication
i love the [ __ ] that voice that
gordon i love that [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
like so so creepy
but it's like a great great great
[ __ ] movie all right uh number seven
the descent from 2005. i probably made
the mistake
of watching this for the first time on
an
airplane um and i hate flying if you
don't know it like stresses me the [ __ ]
out
i was flying either to or from the uk i
can't remember so i was like flying over
the atlantic ocean
there was really really bad turbulence i
was losing my [ __ ]
and i was just kind of like man i need
to like watch a movie and take my mind
off this
[ __ ] plane is maybe going to crash or
whatever so the movie that i chose to
watch
i'm like oh horror movie so i chose to
watch the descent and that was
a mistake because that movie [ __ ]
stressed me the [ __ ] out
i like the movie i bought the movie on
blu-ray and it won't play on my xbox
yeah for some reason it'll play on
blu-ray players yeah
on xbox yeah the blu-ray player in the
living room will play it but the the
xbox in the bedroom must be some kind of
code it's so so good
i mean it's the only blu-ray i have that
won't play on the damn
yeah i know it's weird yeah oh and you
know what else won't play
what my uh that fire that clint eastwood
firefox movie from the 80s will not play
on my
on my xbox but it'll play out there
i wonder if it's like just some i don't
know it's probably just some little
glitch or something because we don't
usually have like any
trouble fox fire i remember seeing that
on [ __ ] cable back firefox
firefox whatever yeah um yeah
xbox doesn't play blu-ray ps4 and five
do
um our xbox does play plays yeah it'll
play blue race
yeah there's only one that it won't play
and that's yeah
yeah sanders says uh was that the film
with the cave yeah that was the one with
all the women that were going caving and
they
very unwisely decided hey here's this
uncharted well one of them decided and
didn't uh
tell the other women by the way we're in
a completely uncharted uh
you know cave system how's how's that
grab you and they're just like yeah
thanks
[ __ ] and uh then monsters
um but yeah this is like really like
creepy claustrophobic honestly
um i don't i think it would still would
have been a good movie if you didn't
even have the scary monsters in there
but because just because of the
claustrophobia and like [ __ ] them
getting stuck and all that kind of [ __ ]
but the addition of the monsters was
just like so so good and the monsters
look really cool because they look like
like people that would have lived in a
cave for like thousands and thousands
you're like all white and they're all
like [ __ ]
blind and [ __ ] like that they didn't
have eyes yeah they yeah they um
i don't know if they well they didn't
have eyes where they were blind though
okay
as you would be right like if you lived
in a cave forever because what the [ __ ]
can you die for
they could smell stuff and hear stuff
that's like pretty men
um okay where was i okay number six
lake mungo from 2008. we did a review of
this one as well
this was a mockumentary and um
it was it's kind of about a family it's
australian and
it's about a family whose daughter dies
like
in a drowning accident and then
she seems to be haunting their house
yeah i remember this but then halfway
through
you find i don't i we probably spoiled
it on the [ __ ]
other thing but it's like within halfway
through you find out that's not exactly
what's going on but that
maybe i think i remember this yeah it's
like i really really like it because
it's just like this really really creepy
like slow burn
type of and and the way that they did
the mockumentary
the people that they have on there are
so if you didn't know that this was like
a horror movie and it's not real
you would totally buy it yeah i mean
that just the actors that they got are
amazing they're exactly like real people
it's exactly like a real documentary
and so it's just really really well done
and i feel like a lot of people i don't
even think you can buy this [ __ ] on
blu-ray man i don't think um i s i
watched it on
maybe to be or hula i can't remember but
it's it's it's somewhere
you know what i mean it's it's on one of
the free uh services i think
number five good old bubba hotep
all right man go i'll get back with you
yes
you're telling me about that blu-ray oh
okay yeah yeah all right okay
he may have a way to work it out oh okay
could be the region code oh yeah
i didn't think about that it's funny
it'll play on the dvd on the blu-ray
player but we'll play on won't play on
an xbox
yeah i don't know why yeah and it's it's
brand new never been played just
but just had it for a couple years yeah
yeah strange
um what'd i say oh number five bubba
hotep bubba
hotep yeah boba hotep is a masterpiece
more a comedy but it has some horror in
it too
yeah um based on the wonderful short
story by joe r lansdale and honestly the
movie
is almost what i from what i remember
because i've read the story
i think the movie is almost exactly like
the story
it's a masterpiece i love that movie
it's just so good i mean
bruce [ __ ] campbell is so
good in it the tone is the same as
something out of evil dead basically
uh yeah but it does kind of have a but
about a bunch of geriatrics in a [ __ ]
folks on one of them is elvis the other
one is jfk
after the cia
filled his head up with sand after the
shooting and put him back together and
turned him black
yeah that's it and then the other one is
the other one is uh
he believes it it's just it may be true
within within the the theme of the movie
it could be true
okay because crazier [ __ ] than that
happens in the movie sure
oh and then they got what is it hot
blonde cassidy
who was that billy the kid no it was hop
along cass i think it was yeah that
other guy
was a cowboy actor he's in it yeah
they're in the convalescent home
and elvis is in there he's assumed the
identity of an elvis impersonator
yeah and let the impersonators take over
his
uh uh life as elvis and then he died
yeah the impersonator is the one that
they found up in vegas yeah
not the real elvis this is the evidently
the real elvis
and they're in there and they come
across us a mommy
that sucks people an egyptian mommy yeah
in the middle of alabama no was it
alabama or was it no texas
an egyptian mummy in texas that's going
into the damn convalescent home and
sucking people's souls out
through their bottles through their ass
and they're going to try to stop this
[ __ ] to save their friends and the kind
i mean can i
just say yeah it's like i love joe r
lansdale
and i love that he came up with that
[ __ ] story yeah i just i just love
that you got black jfk
black jfk in this [ __ ] wheelchair you
got [ __ ] elvis
in his [ __ ] with his walker and then
you got to [ __ ] hop along cassie
running around dressed up in his cowboy
outfit with a bunch of cap guns
the awesome thing about it well like
okay so bruce campbell's amazing aussie
davis is in this and he just lends the
role like such a gravitas it's
so great and it's it's weird because
it's like
it's funny and it's got horror elements
but it's also like really sweet which is
a very strange thing to say but it's
actually like really really heartfelt
yeah and that's kind of hard to pull off
you know it's about the
it's an end of life story really yeah
yeah it's about
like your last hurrah you're getting so
old you're gonna die
but you're but you're not gonna die
alone you'll be with your friends and
they're all great
celebrities yeah that's that's and it
all makes sense
elvis also has a growth on his dick i
think we forgot to
catch that that place out of the place
comes in [ __ ] massages
putting
she was [ __ ] great too everybody in
this movie is so great
i just [ __ ] love it i love it so much
um okay so
number four the others from 2001. which
one was that
this is the one with nicole kidman and
the two kids and they're in the house
and the kids are like have a light
allergy so she has to um always keep
them in the dark
it's very much it's very very very
loosely based on turn of the screw
um it's not exactly the same story
there's a different thing going on
but um it's kind of kind of kind of like
that and i think it's set during world
war
one i want to say world war one world
war two i can't remember i think it's
world war one but i can't remember
um this is like this big english manor
house but it's just so
i mean i love old school ghost stories
like this
and this was just like what that's
corrected me it wasn't hop along cast it
was the low ranger
that's right yeah i knew it was like one
of those it was that's a fictional
character and i think you know hopalong
cassidy is a fictional character too i
think
or is that a yeah as far as yeah yeah
yeah a little ranger
yeah that poor guy he's like one of
those like boxer shorts with the with
the mask and the
couch got to watch that again yeah we
have that too
yeah i [ __ ] love that movie i've seen
it so many times it's just it and it
makes me laugh like every single [ __ ]
time
especially like what aussie dave is
going they doubted me this color i
[ __ ] love that
but yeah so if you haven't seen the
others it's really good especially like
like old school ghost stories if you
liked the innocence if you liked that
type of thing um it's just really really
good it's really really creepy
got a big twist in there um which i'm
sure most people know what the twist is
but um you know i don't want to be
responsible for spoiling it it's kind of
it's kind of like talking about the
sixth sense they're like bruce was dead
the whole time and they're like god damn
it but
i feel like everyone's seen it so you
know uh number three
sean of the dead yeah 2004. great movie
one of the funniest i mean it's
[ __ ] it's just [ __ ] great it's
like every single scene
in it you the whole thing is like you've
got red on you the whole thing where
they're throwing the records at the
zombie woman
and they they won't do blue monday
because it's like a collection
or whatever and it's just like i love
the i love this sequence where shawn
is going to work in the morning whatever
and there's just like zombies and
destruction like all over the place and
he's just so out of it he doesn't notice
it's like you know what i mean he goes
in to get [ __ ] something out of the
convenience store fridge and there's
like bloody handprints all over and he's
just like
like he doesn't even notice it's like
really [ __ ] imagine if walking dead
was british and it was a comment and
funny
yeah it's good it's classic i mean those
two guys they um
uh what's his name edgar wright and and
then they have made
i mean hot fuzz is great too that's kind
of like a parody of
like buddy cop movies um i haven't seen
it a long time i saw it in the theater
but i remember it being [ __ ]
hilarious
um i don't think it's quite as funny as
sean of the dead but i don't know like
other people's
opinions may differ i guess i like
shauna the dead better because it's more
horror movie
and i'm more into horror movies than i'm
like cop action movies um so
shauna that was funnier to me but
they're both really funny all right
number two
the ring from 2002. now this is the one
exception you know to where i'm saying
it's like oh the american remakes of the
japanese movies are never as good
i am to argue that gore verbinski's
american remake of
ringu is better than the japanese one
fight me um you know what um i saw
the ring first i saw it in the theater
it scared the [ __ ] crap out of me
holy crap and it's like i was just like
it was almost like hereditary level like
it really really bothered me like for
days and days afterward i was like
like i was like all creeped out and so
later i was like oh i should probably
see the japanese original
and i saw it it just didn't i don't know
the japanese it's good but it just
didn't really do anything for me
i don't i don't know what it was um but
the ring with naomi watts was just great
and i
my favorite thing i mean there's so much
great [ __ ]
imagery in it like the horse jumping off
the ship and like
going in the [ __ ] propeller and it's
just
that that one scene where they're
talking about the niece and then they
like
smash cut to her and she's like are in
the closet and her [ __ ] face is all
[ __ ] up and you're like not expecting
it's [ __ ] great
so it's just so it you know it can be
done like they can do a good
american remake if you get somebody that
knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
because i will argue
and this is probably the only time i'll
argue this is like i think that
the american version of the ring is
better than the original japanese one
i can't think of any other ones where
that is the case and
number one on this list
number one is that zach can guess
mulholland drive don't you [ __ ] tell
me this is not a horror movie
because it totally is wikipedia says
it's a horror movie too so
again fight me because um now all of
david lynch's movies
aren't weren't in the wikipedia like you
know because they have this whole list
of horror movies from every year
you know what i mean um i did see
mulholland drive is on there eraserhead
is on there i don't think any of his
other movies are on there although i
would argue
that inland empire might also
be a horror movie the thing about david
lynch is that
his [ __ ] is so [ __ ] weird that
you can't really classify it you know
what i mean you can't classify
if you had if you asked me like what
genre is mulholland drive
it's uh all the genres i don't know it's
it's a horror movie it's a mystery
it's a thriller it's a drama it's just a
weird
[ __ ] movie and it's honestly
mulholland drive
is probably my favorite movie of all
time
probably okay i have seen it zillions of
times i have read
whole like [ __ ] huge books and essays
about [ __ ] about like the symbolism and
what all it all means and everything
it's just so
layered and amazing and i think i did um
i did a review of it a while back i
think when you were in mississippi
so i did it by myself and i didn't even
cover like all the [ __ ] i want to talk
about and i think it was like almost an
hour long
but there's just so much [ __ ]
attention to detail and it's just like a
great [ __ ] um
just the whole like aesthetic of it the
whole mood of it i just [ __ ] love it
there's a whole industry of youtubers
that analyze all that [ __ ] too
yeah i mean so it's so she's in the box
and that she knows that she's in the
movie
she doesn't know that she's in the movie
the director is that kind of [ __ ]
yeah kind of like what they would do to
the shiny they'll pick the shining apart
over analyzing the shiny but i think in
the case but there is a lot of
that [ __ ] in there yeah and stuff like
mulholland drive though i mean that
that's
a bunch of symbolic stuff oh big time
him playing with you and stuff
it's all symbolic and and what amazes me
the most about mulholland drive
is that it was actually supposed to be a
series
because after they had done twin peaks
and that was kind of like a big thing
they so they were going to
have him do another series so he kind of
had this
idea and he had sort of started writing
it up as a series and then after a while
they were like nah never mind we don't
want to do a series
so he's like well [ __ ] it i'm just going
to turn it into a movie and the fact
that it still came out
as like one of the best movies ever and
like so [ __ ] brilliant
and it's it's almost kind of like david
lynch kind of pisses me off in a way
because it's just like
yeah you know i was gonna do this a tv
series and then i just made it into a
movie and oh
there you go it just it was so easy like
he made the most brilliant [ __ ] movie
ever just like with it's like he does it
without even thinking about it and that
makes me really angry but a guy is a guy
he's a film genius yeah but i must
i must say that he's also an acquired
taste i mean well i'm sure
like yeah not everybody's gonna dig it
well i'm like what yeah
you know what i mean it takes me a while
to kind of understand what's going on
and then i'm like wait a minute
it's it's kind of what kind of like the
same quality that kubrick has
except it's [ __ ] he's got that [ __ ]
dialed up to 11. yeah
so well he's super into like surrealism
and he's super into
well i mean he's super into like cinema
and into filmmaking as kubrick was
so a lot of the stuff that he puts in
the movies particularly in mulholland
drive
because it's almost kind of like i have
to see this [ __ ] again because it's
almost kind of like
you know a hollywood mythology so
there's so much stuff in there that
references
other movies i kind of get mulholland
drive and lost highway
they're kind of similar i like lost
highway too but mulholland drive is a
way better
you're you have all that [ __ ] we're
gonna have to do that i don't have lost
highway but i do have mulholland drive i
have a racer head i have
um what the other one i have like a
couple of other ones i don't have inland
empire yet though
i still need to sit through that for a
sec i've seen it two or three times
but that movie i mean i figured out
mulholland drive
um the second or third time i watched it
i was like oh okay i get it
um you know what i mean but it took me a
couple times inland empire
i've seen i think three times and i
still haven't completely figured it out
that is the most david lynchian movie
of all of his highway no which one
inland empire
um that was the last one that he made
before he just
[ __ ] off and like stopped making [ __ ]
although he made that one with the
monkey
showed up hey what's up yeah
yeah what was the lynch movie with
robert blake yeah that was lost highway
lost highway
i gotta see those again man i was
lost highway actually i was really young
when i saw those
i you know i considered myself young at
that at that age i was probably
25 26 around that time and i
didn't quite get what he was doing yeah
they were kind of enjoyable and they
were eerie like wait a minute what the
[ __ ]
yeah his shit's like super creepy and i
wasn't real curious at that time though
yeah
just like yeah [ __ ] that and then after
after the movie was over
pretty much that hardy party [ __ ]
[ __ ] that artifact
i was like yeah and then and then i
would immediately forget that but i do
remember that one scene
i guess it was in lost highway where
they had uh well what's his name and the
damn white makeup yeah that's what they
were just that's what pat was just
saying and he would call himself on the
phone and you're like
i'm at your house right i'm at your
house right now i'm on the phone see
that kind of [ __ ] freaks me out
and david lynch does that a lot in
eastern countries a vote in the back of
the head and i'm like what the [ __ ] he
talking about
[ __ ] like that freaks me out so like any
time like david lynch put some [ __ ] like
if you guys have seen i don't know like
i know a lot of people maybe didn't see
inland empire
but there is a [ __ ] scene in it
within grace of briskey is in there and
[ __ ] um
uh [ __ ] man what's up what's her [ __ ]
name
i don't know laura dern and uh they're
they're sitting in the room
and grace sabrisky is so [ __ ] creepy
she didn't have to do anything like to
be creepy
and she just says something to the other
one was like if it was tomorrow
you would be sitting right over there
yeah and then like they kind of smash
cuts in the next day and she said that
for some reason that just makes like
goosebumps stand up
i don't know why that kind of [ __ ] wears
me out and i will say that mulholland
drive
has easily one of the best
i guess you call it a jump scare in
cinema history
that whole you know and you know what
i'm talking about winky's diner
that is a [ __ ] masterful
scene so so so so creepy yeah pat that
was robert blake
yeah robert blake and then he's in the
white makeup yeah
who ended up being you know they
suspected him of shooting his wife
yeah i don't know if he did but i don't
know i was right
not inside but you know it's hard it
wasn't the same gun
as his yeah it wasn't the same gun was
it a setup did he have a friend do it
there's no telling they couldn't prove
anything
they were fighting but a lot of couples
fight i don't i don't think he did it
i don't think he i don't think he had
anything to do yeah i'm not real sure
but i kind of lean toward maybe not
yeah you know what i mean it wasn't
enough to convict him on no it wasn't
yeah all right so that was the 2000s and
now like we're
to the last list which is which i did
2010 to 2021 because
come on we're only like one year into
the [ __ ] yeah um
so it doesn't mean it doesn't need its
own 2020 and 2021 didn't need their own
[ __ ]
uh didn't blake go to prison for that no
he was no i thought he was acquitted
yeah serpent surfer says the last half
of inland empire is just a crazy [ __ ]
ride
she was so [ __ ] good in that she
totally should have got the oscar and
david lynch thought so too he kept like
taking out like full page ads like hey
give
laura during the oscars she's amazing
and um they didn't unfortunately but
they totally should have
and honestly that that scene at the end
of uh inland empire where
they're going down the hall like in that
hotel or whatever and their faces are
all distorted oh that freaks me out
really bad too
like the second time i watched it i was
just like no i'm just gonna cover my
eyes at this point and i never [ __ ]
do that
it's just so unsettling i don't know why
all right so
uh all right so this is our top 20
or my top 20 from 2010 to 2021.
um let's see seth says did house of a
thousand corpses make the list
it did not it was on there initially but
i had to take it off because like i said
i was trying to win those [ __ ] down to
like 20.
you know um okay so number 20
the lighthouse from 2019 i loved this
[ __ ] movie was that horror
sort of it was just a weird ass [ __ ]
movie i liked the movie
strange strange but see i love that just
make more weird [ __ ]
drinking they're drinking the [ __ ]
lighthouse oil weird
[ __ ] drunker drunker on that damn
[ __ ] mermaid
then the way it ends they go up in the
lighthouse and look into the damn beam
and that's the end of the [ __ ] move
and i was like get the [ __ ] out of here
and it was just like well isn't it it's
based on like greek mythology right yeah
it's based on a mythological i didn't
[ __ ] get any of that
because to me it was just kind of like a
david lynch movie these dudes just
driving each other [ __ ] crazy
the audience liked it yeah and when it
ended it's an insane
when it ended with him looking into the
beam and he's going ah
he's crazy and then it [ __ ] ended and
i'm like oh get the [ __ ] out of here
really
oh man it was a weird movie though i
liked it i didn't see it
like i said people i like and this is
robert eggers the same guy that made the
witch which
may not turn up on the list at some
point later but um
yeah is it i love people that make weird
[ __ ] trying to catch the other dude
jerking off
telling him not to jerk off yeah willem
dafoe like farting in the in robert
pattinson's face
yeah it's [ __ ] great crazy [ __ ] it's
great
that's exactly what two dudes back then
living in a lighthouse that's what would
have happened
they're just kind of going nuts out
there going nuts writing it down you're
jerking off again
don't do it this is so [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] hilarious oh my god all right
getting crazier and crazier they ran out
of whiskey so they started drinking the
damn lighthouse fuel
yeah like you do uh number 19
this might surprise some people the
suspiria remake from 2018.
i totally went into this movie expecting
that i was going to hate it because
if you remember our 70s list suspiria is
my favorite horror movie from the 1970s
and i always said to myself because i
had heard about a remake being done
many many years before it actually came
out and i'm sitting there going i don't
really see the point of it because
if you if it doesn't look like the dario
argento one
um then it's not really suspiria because
the visual
is such an iconic part of that movie
you know what i mean it's like the story
is kind of even incidental
um you know it's just like this creepy
like visual feast and it's like a fairy
tale
so i felt like well if you can't re you
can't recapture the look because only
dario can do that because that's his
thing
but then if you can't recapture the look
then why [ __ ] bother remaking it
because that's kind of like the best
thing about the movie
but they actually i like that they
changed it they went into he went in the
total opposite direction
and made just everything just gray and
like [ __ ] it was east germany and it
was just kind of all
and i really really like that they did
that i also really like
that they incorporated the dance at the
ballet school
into the witchcraft which the original
movie did not do it was a ballet school
in the original movie
but i liked that the dancing in this
version
was actually part of the ritual of them
doing witchcraft on people
i thought that was a really brilliant
original one i think was visually really
cool for the time with all the colors i
mean
everybody's going to say that yeah yeah
i like the the story i don't remember
from the original i don't remember the
original the story being having my
substance
i mean it's i could've had a hard time
following it well she goes to the ballet
school and it's
basically a front for a couple of weeks
yeah well you know that that's going on
but yeah there's like a bunch of other
stuff that's just kind of hard to follow
the the second one was kind of the same
it was a bunch of subtle stuff
it had dancing and had some good-looking
girls
in it they're witches they can do
certain [ __ ]
nothing was really memorable except the
very end
when a damn demon came out and [ __ ]
chopped all their [ __ ] heads off
a demon witch and it was [ __ ] it
looked [ __ ] fantastic god damn
the end was different than the original
and then uh i didn't know what had
happened or why
because so many look it was so subtle
that it didn't really you know i'm kind
of a dummy you know you have to
underline exactly what the [ __ ]
happening i didn't realize that those
witches didn't pass the test
yeah they would come out [ __ ] shop
and then it went away it was just this
damn it looked like a damn
rotten black rotten wet corpse
thing in a dress that [ __ ] stood up
and i don't its head was just
undescribable it was weird looking
and then it went back to hell where it
came from i guess
well yeah like i said that was the whole
point of them and this wasn't really
going on in the original
that much but there was like two
contingents of witches fighting each
other that were like fighting each other
there was over some different
interpretation of the [ __ ] magic that
they were doing
and like i said i don't really want to
spoil the end of this one like i said
this is not this
this ending is not the same as the
original because in the original movie
which is from 1977 so i can spoil away
um you know jessica harper's character
uh
kills the witch yeah that
is not what happens in this one but i
can't but like i said i like
i mean it took some like massive cajones
to even
want to do a new version of suspiria um
and i and it really took some balls too
to just go man i'm gonna go like the
completely opposite direction with it
and
change you know the skeleton of the
story is the same but i'm
totally gonna change the ending like
opposite to what the
original it was okay yeah uh for me not
real memorable
other than that final scene i wish they
had that damn
which demon thing in the whole movie
well they i mean if they kept show if it
appeared and did things and then maybe
like something had an alien
maybe but the rest of it i thought it
was kind of a sleepy movie that's how i
remember it it's not real it wasn't
well it's real long it's very arty um
and you really really have to pay
attention to all the conversations and
all the because it's
complex like the [ __ ] that's going on i
was kind of nodding out over what they
were talking about like what okay
yeah but because you have to keep track
of too much [ __ ] it's like
it's too much too much work man it's too
much too much work my brain hurts
number 18 color out of space
two thousand nights i liked it guys but
i liked it i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i liked it too i mean visually
gorgeous
um the tone of it is kind of weird but
because you had like it was kind of like
serious but then you had nicolas cage
being like
hey i'm starting an alpaca farm and like
all this kind of like crazy kind of [ __ ]
like that
yeah but it's like i don't know it just
it worked for me for some reason some
people say that the movie didn't work
that mandy worked
mandy was a better movie i liked mandy
better but now they were both good
movies i liked mandy better though i
think it was mostly just
the style and the subject matter yeah
and it was the type of story it was
but color out of space was good too it
was just kind of a weird sci-fi horror
movie yeah it was just like
landed in a damn backyard and it was
[ __ ] doing weird [ __ ] you don't know
what the hell's going on and it's
changing [ __ ]
and [ __ ] cage is caging the [ __ ] out
i gotta see it again i want to see it
again did we buy it yeah i got it
yeah i thought we had yeah because we've
seen it on blu-ray yeah that's right
because we just watched it like
i got a deluxe blu-ray version with the
[ __ ] special sleeve and everything
huh yeah that's right you do yeah
i pre-ordered it didn't i yes i
pre-ordered it we got it
in it we got it before they [ __ ] even
we're streaming it
yeah remember yeah because like we
bought it like yeah we had
the early release things and then like i
think shutter added it like a few weeks
later and i was like well [ __ ]
didn't matter though yeah you know yeah
um number 17
the autopsy of jane doe from 2016.
here's another example of you don't need
a lot of
complicated [ __ ] to make an awesome
movie this movie
is set if i remember correctly entirely
in a room in a morgue and it's
like an unfolding supernatural mystery
about this mysterious body of this young
girl that they find
and they're as they're doing the autopsy
[ __ ] gets weirder and weirder and
weirder and like
the mystery starts to like unravel i
think it's on netflix or
at least it was because i'm pretty sure
that's where i watched it but if you
haven't seen autopsy of jane doe it's
just like a really really good
creepy essentially one location
you know what they would call a bottle
movie um
and it's just really really well done
it's just so creepy and just like the
whole time you're just sitting there
going man what the [ __ ] is going on with
this girl's body it's like [ __ ] crazy
but yeah really really good uh number 16
uh the babadook 2014.
i really really i know like a lot of
people said oh the kid and it is
annoying but
which he was but he was supposed to be
annoying um
i just really liked the aesthetic of the
book i really liked the aesthetic of the
monster
i didn't have a problem because i know
some people were like oh this is a new
thing with
you know all the a24 type horror and
everything where
you know though the monster is never
real it's always like a representation
of grief or whatever
but the thing is it's like yeah but you
can still watch it as like a creepy
monster movie
too you don't have to take away the
subtext if you don't want to i mean
obviously that's what the subtext
is but i saw it i don't remember much
about it you can just watch it as like a
creepy horn because it's super creepy
like the babadook is creepy
that i'd have to see it again he's with
the little monster and he has like the
[ __ ] hat and like little fingers and
he looks kind of like a shadow
sort of it's like i mean just i love the
whole aesthetic of it it was like super
super cool
um number 15 gonna go with uh the
invisible man
it's pretty good from 2020 uh with
elizabeth moss yeah
i mean i like it's also great because
this is what you want to do if you know
because i know they wanted to do the
dark universe
and then they made the mommy with tom
cruise and it was just like a stupid
action movie instead of being like a
creepy horror movie i'm gonna have to
see it
which is what i mean it looked even from
the trailer i was like man that was
dumb as hell but you can why did they do
that you could probably get it cheap now
though
you probably can't because that's that
came out a while back i see [ __ ] tom
doing but yeah so that's what they were
gonna do but then like after the mummy
kind of didn't do all that well uh they
were like okay well we still
want to do those but just you know take
the [ __ ] concept and do something
different with it
and honestly i think this was the best
way to go
like the invisible man that's it was
updated um
you know it was just the acting in it
was amazing it was like just a really
really great
thriller we saw in the theater we did
yeah
yeah yeah i think it came out last
january something like that
yeah we saw it back then it was like one
of the newer movies that wasn't totally
forgettable
you know yeah a lot of that [ __ ] was
just totally forgettable but that one
that one really stood out yeah it stood
out yeah it definitely did
um serpent surfer says i watched the
mommy while i was in the hospital after
surgery and it was worse than the
physical pain i was in
it just i could tell from the trailer i
was like that looks so bad
it looked like the like the the mummy
movies from
the 90s like with uh brendan fraser
that's what i want to say
it look i remember it looking retro and
i would like to see a [ __ ] big old
retro [ __ ] dumbass [ __ ] action
movie with tom cruise in it
jumping out of [ __ ] planes and
fighting those
[ __ ] fighting down punching mummy he's
playing
the plagues of egypt coming after him
and [ __ ]
that pride is probably hilarious i mean
i love i love like the old universal
mummy like with boris karloff and stuff
um which honestly was kind of more of a
drama
but i just love the whole aesthetic of
the makeup in that was so [ __ ] good
like boris karloff looked so [ __ ]
cool in that
and i just feel like if you're gonna do
a remake of the mummy do something more
like that like do something said
like he's an archaeologist and he's like
set all this kind of [ __ ] with like
oh it's a big [ __ ] yeah gives all
this cgi
[ __ ] flying everywhere it's like just
stop it stop it i really like tom and
mission impossible just gotta say
i don't give a [ __ ] what y'all say i
like well i don't i don't mind the
mission impossible movies but we'll
think about
all the movies of their time yeah but
there's a lot of actual real good man i
like to follow it was a fallout rogue
and rogue nation or some [ __ ] yeah we
saw him in the theater i i [ __ ]
enjoyed it i liked fallout a lot
it was good i mean yeah i'm not totally
averse i'm just saying i don't like
i to me i i never liked that thing where
there's like well let's make a horror
movie
but they make it like this big cgi
wankfest that's why i could never get
into like the underworld movies and all
that kind of stuff it's like you're
making it into an action
movie yeah i want to see like a creepy
horror movie if i wanted to watch an
action movie i'd watch a [ __ ] action
movie you know what i'm saying although
you got to say that dracula untold was
the same way and i really i did like
that i like that i did like that one
yeah
so you know but that one was kind of
boot that was like old that was like a
period piece and it's like that just had
some cool [ __ ]
i don't know well what he could do yeah
see that
yeah that was that was cool yeah but i'm
gonna say that with the invisible man i
think they absolutely went in the right
direction with that
or they made it like a thriller but it
was kind of like you know
using that concept um number 14
midsummer yeah liked it from 2019
yeah it was totally different
than uh zarya's obviously totally
different than hereditary which will
probably
probably it'll definitely fail during
that movie well we'll get yeah
we'll get into that but like um
midsummer was cool because
man i really have to see that one again
because there was a lot well
ari astor really likes to like do all
kind of like weird hidden [ __ ] in his
movies
i liked it and you have to like
midsummer
it basically tells you everything that's
gonna happen in the movie like in the
credits like it because it's scrolling
across that [ __ ]
drawing or whatever like that mural yeah
and it shows every single thing that's
going to happen in the movie
like in that mural it's amazing if you
liked if you liked a wicker man you'd
like this
it's not the new wicker man the old
wicker man it's in that same
kind of neofolk kind of deal it's all
these
where where they were scandinavians
weren't they yeah
yeah all these scandinavians living out
in some
cult deep in the honky motherland living
the way it was before the empire and all
that [ __ ]
back with the druids and [ __ ] all
this weird magic
and all the weird [ __ ] white folks had
to do to get the trees to grow
and to get the rain to fall and they're
still doing it
and you're like you crazy [ __ ]
you're going to do that [ __ ]
setting people on fire and doing them
embarrassing my bear suits and setting
them on
fire just so the harvest is good you
guys are [ __ ] nuts but they [ __ ]
believe the [ __ ]
and it's like they're back in the day
and just the way it was is it
it was an eerie creepy movie because you
knew bad [ __ ] was gonna happen remember
the black dude he's like oh no i'm out
of here oh no no this is just just let
me go they got his ass though
it was a horror movie oh big you went
down there and [ __ ]
they [ __ ] did what they wanted to
to you you know in some religious
[ __ ] ceremony
it was it was better than than than
wicker man actually it was like this
in a lot of ways yeah he was better than
wicker man um
i liked it and a lot of people didn't
like this movie
it well it got mixed reviews some people
[ __ ] loved it and some people were
like man
it was [ __ ] weird man yeah like all
the [ __ ] trees were doing this [ __ ]
like you were on
lsd like the whole time it's like i love
that pretty much the whole thing was set
like in bright daylight
yeah and it made it weirder it made it
yeah that's it's really hard to pull
that off and they were doing it out in
the open
in these fields with everybody watching
and [ __ ] yeah because they're [ __ ]
the lesson is is that [ __ ] they got
some people that believe some [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] that's not gonna stop them
from doing it yeah they're gonna do and
they live like way out in the middle of
nowhere it's like there's nobody there
to say hey don't do that you're kind of
like uh limited to what your belief
system is
yeah the belief system dictates what you
do and
that's what they believed in yeah that's
what it was in the wicker man
story too yeah the same same kind of
human sacrifice stories
and they were all like happy and yeah
and everything yeah you know and they
kind of do that and in a way that makes
it creepier because they're not sinister
at all
yeah and they live all communally yeah
you know they all seem like super
friendly
and nice and everything kind of like
free sex and free love and [ __ ] and then
they've
just got to see it it's good it's crazy
serpent surfer says i'm surprised there
aren't more pig and folk horror movies
it's an untapped market see i always
thought that too because
i can't really think of all that many
other than mid-summer and that's like i
said i'm really glad that you know
people are kind of
maybe maybe we'll get a mini boom
literally put that [ __ ] on and you're
listening to [ __ ] you listen to them
death in june and yeah current 93 in
nature and organization yeah it'll fit
right in
and uh was a death in rome and yeah and
rome
and [ __ ] yeah those bands those neo
folk
goth industrial type and it would fit
right into that creepy ass
i'm eating this even in the 70s you had
wicker man you had
blood on satan's claw yeah um
was there the devil rides out was that
like folk or
i don't know um i can think of a couple
books harvest home
by tom tryon uh which they actually made
into a tv movie although it wasn't that
good
but the book was very folk horror i just
i feel like there's not enough of it
like you're like that just says he'd put
wicker man above midsummer but i in
terms of a classic
yeah i never think in terms of a movie i
kind of think mid-summer was better
because it
it didn't beat around the bush it got
right to the point of what the deal was
you know what i mean like there wasn't
any real build up to it to speak of
you know what i mean there wasn't they
weren't keeping the secrets of what was
going on
yeah and then finally the cop figures it
out no right from the very beginning
it's a whole movie of that yeah so i
kind of liked it better
uh you weren't waiting for it to happen
it happened through the whole [ __ ]
thing
yeah so i was i liked it i was laughing
at fourth door downstairs it's all fun
and games until the old guy jumps off a
cliff
until like [ __ ] jumps off the cliff
stay back bye
oh that was so gross refreshed like his
[ __ ]
face just kind of like he was so so
nasty
yeah uh okay number 13 little movie
called
creep now this is from there's been
several movies called creep the one i'm
talking
about is the one from 2014 with mark
duplass
it's found footage but
it's different um so basically the setup
is that this dude named joseph
has uh puts an ad for a videographer
and his story is um my wife is pregnant
but i'm dying of cancer
so i want you the videographer to
document my life so that you know when
my kid is born
he'll see like what his dad was like
so this guy goes and films the dude
and the dude joseph is
not right but you don't know exactly
what's going on
or what's the matter with him it's just
really really unsettling like at first
you don't know it's like is he a
murderer or is he just like really
really awkward or does she yourself like
a really strange
sense of humor and it's just like and it
just keeps getting like weirder and
weirder and weirder and it's just it's
so so good
and actually they made a creep too it
might be on netflix still
um and they made a creep too as well
which is also very good i think the
first one's a little bit better but the
second one's good too
um and like i said so if you know it's
found footage but
don't let that deter you uh because it's
actually really good
uh number 12 tucker and dale versus
evil 2010. i don't remember that there's
a horror comedy
about two lovable rednecks
who have a fishing cabin out in the
middle of nowhere and they're fixing it
up
and these snotty horrible college
students
are camping out in the woods and they
somehow get the idea that the rednecks
are going to kill them because it's go
so it's like a parody of
you know the the hicks in the woods like
killer hicks in the woods
genre because in this one it's like
reversed the hicks are like the good
guys and they're like super sweet and
awesome
and the college kids are oh yeah they're
all douchebags
and they all start and the funny thing
and it just keeps ramping up because
because the college kids keep
essentially killing themselves in really
really stupid ways because
they're afraid of these dudes like you
the one like runs into a wood chipper
and it's like
just [ __ ] like that and it's [ __ ]
hysterical yeah
in in some ways this uh
this movie is kind of like the american
version of um
shawn of the dead in a way it has a
shawn of the dead type quality where you
have
local people in a [ __ ] weird
situation
but uh well maybe it is not quite the
same it just
it's just a uh yeah the people that you
thought were gonna be the bad guys
were actually the good guys and the good
guys the people you thought were the
good guys were actually the bad guys
it's just it's a reversal and it's just
really really funny
yeah the way like [ __ ] keeps escalating
because
the the hicks you know tucker and dale
are trying to help
these kids because they think that the
kids are like killing themselves and
they're like oh my god it must be like a
suicide pact we have to do something to
help them
and the so like but them trying to help
and the kids being scared of them and
thinking they're murderers
keeps like leading to these increasingly
absurd situations where these college
kids keep killing themselves they're
like
ridiculous i'm gonna go ahead and say
that
it is our it is our version of shawn of
the dead except it's
it's in the form of a slasher it's a lot
like it's that same tone
yeah it's real horrible and it's another
one too where
the characters of tucker and dale are
just so lovable
and their friendship is just so awesome
so it really has like this great like
emotional heart to it which i think is
really
cool um you know yeah if you haven't
seen it it's like super super funny
little debbie real quick i'm starving
you're getting oh well now yours now
you're starving
you and your hormones his hormones are
just like all over the [ __ ] place
yeah manga says the wood chipper scene
is a work of i love that [ __ ] seat so
much
and i just love that they're just so
befuddled they have no idea what's going
on
and it's just like that i feel you feel
so bad for them because they're just
like what the [ __ ]
like all these college kids are just
running in here and killing themselves
in horrible ways and they can't figure
out how to stop it
it's just like super super funny all
right um number
11 i'm gonna go with
the witch from 2015.
again robert egger same guy that did the
lighthouse
i you know this movie
like as you can tell like robert eggers
he's one he's committed to like just
making [ __ ]
weird ass works of art movies and he
doesn't really give a [ __ ] if people
like i guess like them or not so i love
that this movie
is almost all the dialogue is
from uh [ __ ] that happened like you know
um
witchcraft trial [ __ ] like that happened
at the time so it's all like period
accurate dialogue
all of the clothing is period accurate
it was all like made by hand
so he really i mean it's just it's a
work of art it's beautiful to look at
and it's just like a real creepy like
the whole thing with the goat and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] is like so so creepy
but yeah it's like really really good um
you know i can see like some people if
you're not into more like arty farty
horror because i know that some people
aren't
um then probably you i don't know just
like
think it was slow or something like that
but i don't know i really got into it i
got into the whole like [ __ ] tone of
it i just thought it was like really
really awesome
uh number 10 upgrade
from 2018. this was kind of a sci-fi
horror with logan marshall green and uh
he basically
this i don't know it's it's a horror
movie it's sci-fi it also kind of has a
little bit of dark comedy in it as well
um you know it's it's almost the same
story as robocop
i want to say which one are you talking
about upgrade
oh upgrade was awesome i liked that one
so not really horrible
movie though well kind of it had horror
elements to it
it was like horror action dark comedy
sci-fi i guess so you know i'm gonna
call it like i said wikipedia had it on
their horror movie list
so i'm gonna i'm gonna put it on there
yeah this this was actually one of my
favorite movies uh that came out in 2018
yeah uh sophie sent it to us yeah and
that's i'm glad she did because i had
not seen it never heard of it
and um it's it's weird because i was
just reading earlier today
somebody was talking somebody wrote like
a big long thing about this
from a couple years back and i read it
but yeah it's just i
loved one of my favorite things is logan
marshall green in this
like the the physical
uh physicality of the role because you
know basically it's he has like an ai
that is like ass kicking but he doesn't
realize i guess so it's just kind of
like
his body is doing [ __ ] that he's not
like in control of
like as he gets taken over so it's just
like the
the great looks on his face like when he
just starts like
beating the [ __ ] out of somebody and
he's just like what the [ __ ] am i doing
right now like he doesn't have any
control over his body it's like really
really good
um number nine the bae
from 2012. this is another mockumentary
and it's basically about
this um parasite it's a parasite
movie and it's super super disgusting
and
this again is one just like i was
talking about with lake mungo where
you could totally see this being like a
real
documentary if you didn't know that it
was fake it's basically about this small
seaside town
they all start getting this weird like
parasite it's like it eats their tongues
or like replaces their tongue
basically looks like one of those big
like roly-poly things but
big you know what i mean um and it kind
of like eats people's tongues and then
like it takes over this whole town like
over the fourth of july weekend
it's like so it's so it's super skin
crawly it's super gory
and it's all done like a mockumentary
you know what i mean so it's really
really good
so if you haven't seen that uh then i
would recommend it
uh number eight i'm gonna go with i'm
the pretty thing that lives in the house
this is another one that is real i guess
it's kind of divisive because it's
another one of those sort of like slow
burn already farty ghost story type of
things and it's kind of like ambiguous
like you're not entirely sure like who's
a ghost and who's dead and [ __ ]
but there was just something about this
one
that this is one of those movies where
it had like these really really creepy
shots of like a
like an empty room and then there would
be like a doorway and it was dark
and you were always kind of like
expecting [ __ ] to like pop out of this
and like sometimes like nothing would
happen but it just had this really like
it really gave me like a palpable like
feeling of dread
like through the whole thing just from
like the camera angles and like the way
[ __ ] was shot
and so you really didn't have to show
much of anything because i don't think
there was any like big hey ghost action
until maybe the very end
if i'm remembering it correctly but most
of it was just like it was atmosphere it
was just all the way it was shot like
just
it was just so so well done i just
really really liked it i think oz
perkins directed that
now that i'm thinking about it anthony
perkins is sermon's in there laughing at
me tom's reviews are all i didn't see it
gotta watch it
this isn't my list this is jenny's list
yeah jenny's seen a lot more movies than
me yeah
a lot more her taste is better than mine
too
she likes that already party [ __ ] she's
a writer i like arty farty [ __ ] but i
also like
gory [ __ ] i like slashers yeah i like
horror comedies i like all different
kind of horror movies
well hi pook oh my goodness look the
closet door is open do you want to go in
there
you want to go to kitty narnia i keep
telling her narnia's in there but she
doesn't believe me
all right so where are we number seven
well i won't wait till tom comes back
for this one because he's actually seen
this movie
so i guess i have to wait till he comes
back did he eat both of those things
okay well he poured more lemonade in
here and all my ice melted oh no
no oh no oh no bring some more eyes no
okay
wait wait wait oh
i think my [ __ ] crashed
is it gonna come back or
i don't know it's like it's still going
on yours
i'm looking over at his tablet and i
still i'm still on there talking like
normal but on my [ __ ] it's like not
i don't know man it's really really
weird [ __ ] up again well
it it looked like it didn't really drop
it was just you it was just me just your
monitor
but how's that ram look can you see that
it's it's fine actually it's 31 percent
that's good what is the connection
any warnings on it let me see
oh oh yeah you touched it and it [ __ ]
well i gotta touch it
yeah i know i'm saying it has something
to do
with ram i think yeah lost the
connection
[ __ ] well yeah
it's just it completely froze
completely froze yeah well okay no we're
back
are we yes no
try to say you froze again this is uh
see it's weird because it still says
excellent connection but it could just
be that my ship
just it's weird like it nothing's moving
nothing's moving it's kind of doing its
thing they can
they can we can text yeah
it's just my it just keeps
okay it came back nope it didn't
this is so frustrating this is so
frustrating
okay let's do this let's start another
stream yeah we're gonna have to start a
new one because this is not
this isn't cool okay they want me to
give